he hablado mucho sobre la idea general
para tener una variable de estado por
ejemplo qué es la energía interna del
sistema en cualquier punto de este
diagrama de presión volumen esa variable
siempre debe ser la misma en cualquier
punto siempre que no importa cómo nos
movamos por ejemplo a lo largo del ciclo
de carnets y si pensamos en una energía
interna en el punto a a lo largo del
ciclo al volver al punto a no debió
haber cambiado sólo depende de su
posición en el diagrama y no de cómo
llegamos a ese punto a lo mejor podemos
tener una trayectoria muy loca dea y que
regrese al punto a pero no debe cambiar
esa variable solo es dependiente de su
estado no de cómo llegamos ahí por eso
es que el calor es algo que no podemos
realmente usar como una variable de
estado por ejemplo si tratara de definir
una un estado relacionado con el calor
digamos que el calor contenido no y que
el cambio en el calor contenido es igual
a la cantidad de calor que al que
agregamos al sistema bueno si volvemos a
nuestro ciclo de carnota aquí
mi contenido de calor aquí digamos que
era 10
agregamos un calor q no a lo largo de
desde ave luego debe hace está diabético
así que no pasó nada y desea de seguimos
calor verdad a través de q2 ok a través
de q2 y luego de de a no no pasó nada
porque era diabético así que si hubo
cierto cambio así que la cantidad de
calor neta que tenemos a lo largo del
ciclo es uno menos q 2 y sabemos que
este número es mucho mayor que este otro
la cantidad neta de calor que agregamos
al sistema era la cantidad de trabajo
que realizamos en el sistema porque la
energía interna no cambió así que si
esto es 0 la cantidad de calor que
agregamos es igual al trabajo realizado
a lo largo del ciclo ok y de hecho la
energía interna como que no cambia de
cero y esta porción sombreada que pongo
en amarillo que es el área dentro del
ciclo demostramos que era el trabajo que
realizaba la es de este ciclo verdad
y así si agregamos cierta cantidad de
calor al sistema digamos que empezamos
con 10 aunque lo que sea no sé con qué
empezamos pero digamos que con 10 le
damos una vuelta al ciclo y ahora tengo
10 más w luego otra vuelta y tenemos 10
+ 2 w otra vuelta y 10 más 3 dobles así
que no puede ser una variable de estado
porque es completamente dependiente de
qué es lo que hacemos a lo largo del
ciclo verdad en cada ciclo le agregamos
una w que es el trabajo así que no es un
estado legítimo como variable de estado
por ya que nuestro cambio no hay que hay
que ignorarlo porque nuestro cambio no
nos da 0 ahora ya que conocemos uno que
agregamos cierto calor vamos a la parte
interesante aquí es este que agregamos
una cantidad mayor de temperatura y acá
abajo en q2 en realidad quitamos una
cantidad muy poca de temperatura así que
podríamos definir otra variable de
estado que pudiéramos tener que después
de un ciclo volvamos al mismo valor
déjenme vamos a experimentar bueno
un experimento como tal porque yo ya sé
a qué es a lo que quiero llegar pero
vamos a suponer que yo defino una nueva
variable ese y que su cambio en el
cambio de la variable s solo estamos
haciendo una definición aquí sea el
calor agregado al sistema entre la
temperatura a la cual se le agregó ahora
no sé lo que sea ese todavía lo veremos
en vídeos futuros quizás con mayor
inducción de lo que esto significa ya
que lo tengamos en nuestra mente pero
vamos a ver si al menos esto es una
variable válida de estado a lo largo del
ciclo de carnota vamos a ver cómo es
nuestro cambio en ese ok entonces para
que sea un cambio legítimo de estado de
su pónganse que empezamos con 100 ok y
al darle la vuelta al ciclo de kart
notebook deberíamos volver a 100 es
decir que nuestro cambio en ese debe ser
cero así que vuelta s a lo largo del
ciclo déjenme déjenme escribir delta
delta s con otro color del tae se
a lo largo del ciclo de carnot le voy a
poner esa c
ok vamos a lo largo del ciclo de carne
debe ser igual a bueno cuando vamos de
ave vamos a ver qué pasa qué temperatura
tenemos tenemos un calor 1 y una
temperatura de 1 verdad luego vamos debe
hacer que es a diabético es decir no
agregamos calor verdad no agregamos
ningún calor así que sí sí le agregamos
0 es eso es porque es calor / cualquier
temperatura lo mejor la temperatura
cambia pero el calor es cero así que así
se queda cuando vamos de shehadeh
tenemos una temperatura de 2 pero
tenemos q 2 como calor verdad ahí
teníamos nuestro depósito de calor q2
después vamos debe a que es también un
proceso a diabético y por lo tanto no
hay transferencia de calor así que
tenemos otro cero
estos son ceros no importa insisto
tenemos un calor entre no sé qué
temperatura pero como el calor es cero
bueno está ok entonces para que ese sea
una variable de estado valida todo esto
nos debe quedar igual a cero vamos a ver
si es eso cuál es nuestro cambio en ese
de nuestra variable mística a lo largo
del ciclo de carnet bueno esto
simplemente es q no entre t 1 más q 2
sobre t 2 y vamos a ver qué q 2 de hecho
es negativo así que cuál es la cantidad
de q1 como calculamos que uno bueno como
estamos en esta parte de la terna de ave
nuestro cambio en la energía no existe
es decir el cambio en la energía es
igual a cero y el calor agregado es
igual al trabajo realizado del estado a
al estado b que es el área debajo de la
curva desde
a del estado a hasta el estado de verdad
solo sería el área debajo de esa curva
cuál es esa área bueno déjenme hacerlo
esto un poquito aparte así que qué 11 es
igual al trabajo realizado desde hasta
ve y el trabajo recordemos que lo
podemos ver como el presión la presión
por el cambio en el volumen
vamos a hacer bastante cálculo aquí así
que vamos a ponerlo en nuestro término
de cálculo debe es un pequeño cambio en
el volumen y vamos a integrar sobre
todos esos pequeños cambios verdad debe
es un pequeño cambio y entonces al
multiplicar por b estamos calculando el
área de rectángulos y vamos a sumar
todos esos verdad muy bien vamos a sumar
todos esos desde el volumen en a en el
estado a hasta el volumen en el estado b
y luego quién es q 2 quien va a ser q 2
bueno q 2 es igual esencialmente la
misma cosa verdad pero vamos a tomar la
suma del trabajo realizado por por el
sistema el pdv ok y que en realidad es
el trabajo realizado hacia el sistema de
verdad porque estamos comprimiendo y por
eso es que q 2 va a ser negativo pero
bueno esto lo vamos a tomar cuál es
nuestro punto inicial bueno empezamos en
el en el estado c y terminamos en el
estado de entonces los volúmenes van de
c a d
cómo evaluamos estas integrales bueno ya
hemos hecho esto en algunos vídeos
anteriores sólo vamos a solo que en
otras circunstancias ok
así que q1 y q2 van a tener la misma
expresión excepto por los límites de
integración y lo único que tengo que ver
es que estamos cambiando la presión
respecto al volumen la temperatura sigue
siendo la misma a lo largo de esos de
esos procesos así que si recordamos esta
fórmula de la de los gases ideales
si dividimos ambos lados por b tenemos
que es igual a nrc
sobre b y recordemos que en estos
procesos la temperatura no está
cambiando si sustituimos esto en las
integrales
ya podemos tener a p como función de b y
calculamos ahora si el área debajo de
esa curva verdad así que que uno va a
ser igual a la integral de b a hasta bbb
de p que en este caso es n r t sobre b
dv
y q2 va a ser igual a la misma integral
solo que con otros límites de cbc
abed de nrc sobre b bebe y simplemente
estoy haciendo dos integrales en
paralelo que realmente es la misma
integral pero cambiando los límites
verdad ok entonces cómo resolvemos esto
bueno sabemos que en ambos casos estamos
moviéndonos a lo largo de la curva
isoterma así que la temperatura es
constante de hecho en este caso la
temperatura es de 1 de 1 verdad teníamos
nuestro depósito de calor que la
mantenía a temperatura de uno y en el
otro lo mantenía a temperatura t2 verdad
t2 se movía de shehadeh y teníamos un
depósito que de hecho era frío de hecho
era frío y cedía más bien sería calor
muy bien entonces vamos a suponer que n
de hecho es constante porque es el
número de moléculas eres definitivamente
una constante y tf1 también es constante
así que q no lo podemos reescribir como
rt 1 por la integral de vea hasta bb de
1 sobre b dv
y de hecho q 2 también lo podemos
escribir de esta forma nr de 2 la
integral del bc abed de 1 sobre b dv
muy bien ahora vamos a realizar estas
integrales que son bastante directas
cuál es la anti derivada de 1 sobre b
eso es el logaritmo natural verdad
entonces esto nos queda como nrc 1 por
el logaritmo natural de de y esto
evaluado de bb menos menos evaluado en
vea y q2 bueno déjenme déjenme resolver
de una vez esta ecuación así que esto
que va a ser igual el logaritmo natural
de bb menos el logaritmo natural de beas
simplemente es el logaritmo natural de
bb entre b
ya lo hemos hecho varias veces espero
recuerdes esto y esto lo multiplicamos
por mrt 1 y esto es 1 ahora
de la misma forma q 2 a quien va a ser
bueno simplemente q2 va a ser n r de 2
por el logaritmo natural bueno de hecho
es la integral de bs a bb a bb perdón y
esto es el logaritmo natural de b
sobre bc
ok muy bien ahora cuál era nuestra
pregunta original estábamos viendo bajo
que como podríamos ver si esta variable
mística s es una variable de estado
legitima verdad es decir queríamos ver
si su cambio a lo largo del ciclo era 0
ok
su cambio está dada por esta expresión
con 1 / t 1 más q 2 / t 2 así que vamos
a ver qué pasa con 1 sobre t 1 es lo
mismo que dividir entre t 1 y aquí se
van las t1 es verdad de este lado
dividimos entre t 2 ok y se van las de 2
se cancelan así que nuestro cambio de
nuestra variable mística es a lo largo
del ciclo de carnota es uno entre t 1
más q 2 sobre t 2 que es igual a por de
este lado es n r se cancelaron las t1
símica logaritmo natural de bebé sobre b
a ok eso es esta parte de aquí y luego
sumamos
sumamos nr se cancelaron las de 2 de
esta forma por el logaritmo natural dvd
sobre b c ok perdón
esto era verde sobre b c ok esto es
veces ya que era un ave aquí muy bien
vamos a ver qué podemos hacer esto es
igual ya casi llegamos
esto es igual factor izando a n r aunque
podemos factorizar eso esto es el
logaritmo natural de bebé entre beat por
más el logaritmo natural del bede sobre
bc esto es el logaritmo natural de bebés
sobre b vea
bebé sobre veces ya sabemos que suma de
logaritmos es el logaritmo del producto
ahora todo esto es nuestro cambio de
nuestra variable s a lo largo del ciclo
de carnota y ahora esto aquí es igual
bueno qué
qué pasaría si dividimos bueno déjenme
pensar la mejor forma de describir esto
digamos que divido el numerador y el
denominador por veces
ok quizás quizás la mejor forma digamos
que en vez de multiplicar voy a dividir
pero voy a dividir entre el recíproco
del segundo del segundo factor es decir
voy a escribir el logaritmo natural de
bb sobre vea y en vez de multiplicar voy
a dividir pero dividido entre el
recíproco de este desde esta expresión
que es vece sobre vd
y todo esto multiplicado por nr esto es
el cambio en la variable c solo lo que
hice fue en vez de expresar lo como
multiplicación lo expresé como división
ahora ya verás la importancia del vídeo
anterior verdad que aquí es igual esto
en el vídeo anterior les demostré que
bebe sobre b
es igual a veces sobre verde así que
realmente todas esas operaciones
complicadas y raras que hicimos nos
llevaron a esta conclusión así que esta
cantidad que enmarque en realidad es una
verdad si dividimos algo entre sí mismo
esto nos queda 1
si eso es igual a 1 cuál es el logaritmo
natural de 1 es decir nuestro cambio en
la variable s es igual a n r logaritmo
natural de 1 y cuál es el logaritmo
natural de 1 es decir que a la que me da
1 pues eso es 0 así que nr x 0 es igual
a 0 no importa qué tan grande o chico
sea n o r esto es simplemente cero así
que ya lo tienen
tenemos una variable de estado legal muy
bien definida ajá ya que definimos
nuestro cambio en s
igual al valor agregado al sistema valor
agregado al sistema entre su temperatura
baja y entonces nos quedó que esto
resulta ser un campo una variable de
estado muy bien definida así que
esto está esto significa que al menos
tenemos cierta propiedad de algo no
sabemos aunque espero que se conserva
después de un ciclo de carnota es decir
sólo depende de su posición en el
diagrama no sé con qué empecé pero
después de hacer un ciclo muy loco
volvemos al mismo punto y entonces
tenemos la misma cantidad verdad nuestro
cambio en ese va a ser cero así que ese
va a ser una buena variable de estado
pero no sabemos idea de que es no
tenemos idea de qué es pero sabemos que
es variable de estado y su
interpretación lo dejaremos para otro
vídeo